[Musique]
jamais aucune information sur le micro
entreprise très utile pour ce qui est
des marches
ça nous apprend la fiscalité des charges
je suis venu pour apprendre beaucoup de
choses sur la société cofigeo la société
fiscales et comptables ou j'avais
quelques notions mais qui datent de
l'école et donc voilà j'avais besoin de
me remettre un jour sur certains points
les cotisations sur les questions qu'on
se pose sur la retraite est ce qu'on
peut dispenser chômage voilà toutes ces
petites choses qui faisaient peur on est
accompagnée on n'est pas tout seul il
m'a servi a pris le plein d'informations
surtout qu'on est pas mal de choses
quand même sur les cages n'était pas
calé et ce stage par permis de voir tout
ça en détail cette formation j'ai plus
qu'un implant fait sur plusieurs mois
pour savoir tout ce qu'il affirme
administrative tout ce qui est à faire
sur les impôts je sais tout ce qui la
ferme avait vraiment la musique je vais
les réponses aux questions que je
m'étais posé et de la 10 ans et qui avec
l'aja préfère mes baskets
les formateurs avait été très dynamique
et ont réussi nous accrocher à nous
intéresser ici où je vais il était aussi
très à l'écouté on a pu poser toutes les
questions individuellement la famille
commentaire pourquoi des est sûr c'est
que vous allez faire c'est comme une
humiliation
on rencontre les gens ici ça m'a
conforté dans les choix que j'ai fait
enrichissant sympathique
j'ai posé toutes les questions que je me
sens plus à l'aise mon sens prêt et
j'aurais pas les stages là tout de suite
j'ai surtout pris conscience que je
maîtrisais pas du tout le sujet avant le
stage en fait et ça m'a permis de
l'identifier les points qu'il fallait
que j'aille profond 10 pour vraiment
pouvoir créer mon entreprise
cet acte qu'on pouvait faire autant et
des moufles et c'était un très bon
moment une bonne semaine avec le bon
goût qui nous a permis de créer des
liens avec d'autres professionnels nous
mais j'aurais regretté
c'est très chiant c'est compliqué voilà
c'est pas facile à se libérer une
semaine comme ça mais franchement je la
conseille sans passer par là et des
choses qui est personnellement je le
regrette pas c'est un des nôtres et j'ai
essayé de lancer sur internet
c'est très compliqué beaucoup
d'informations et c'est là où on est
cadré les intervenants peut poser nos
questions avec le recul et vu les
enfants que j'ai eus ce stage est
obligatoire parce que c'est quelque
chose qui nous apporte vraiment un
dirigeant d'entreprise
les régions traditionnellement aux
responsabilités chez soi de monter son
attrait et d'un dîner parents comment ce
concept japonais est de mettre toute
personne qui veut créer une entreprise
il est passé dans la chambre de métiers
simple retiens que du positif et ça sera
clair
[Musique]